the monumental stress of the pandemic
has had a drastic impact
on people's mental health including the
veterans in our community
for decades organizations across the
valley have dedicated their time
to supporting the emotional well-being
of those who have served
reporter kate houston is live in the
newsroom tonight to break down how
veterans and military families
can receive help kate yes orco operation
homefront a non-profit dedicated to
supporting local military families
says 22 veterans die by suicide every
single day
they hope by offering emotional and
financial support they can relieve some
of that stress
and keep veterans in our community happy
and healthy
i have a long family history of air
force mark porter joined the air force
in 1975
at the end of the vietnam war pretty
much right out of high school
my job in the air force was aircraft
weapons systems throughout his 17 years
he was stationed all over the united
states as well as germany for three
years he says one of the main points of
stress comes from family separation
and the pressure that puts on a spouse
you control the bills
you pay the rent you pay the utilities
when the bill collectors come
you got to take care of it if one of the
kids gets six you
have to take care of it porter says
stress can pile on when men and women
leave the service and try to re-enter
the workforce
there's a lot of jobs that you have when
you're in the military like aircraft
weapons systems
doesn't relate to a civilian job they
don't put bombs on commercial jets
so you yours you get out and you say
okay now what am i going to do
non-profit operation home front has been
helping individuals answer that question
for the past
15 years a lot of our military members
have got that
pride and and they are fearful of i
don't want to ask i don't want to be
a bother i don't want to feel like i'm a
burden to somebody
we don't want that you've served our
country honorably we are there for you
through financial and emotional support
operation homefront is offering some
stability to local military families
veterans and caregivers over the years
they've even provided homes to veterans
that need them like mark porter who's
now paying it forward and volunteers for
the organization
you're not alone don't don't think you
you know pick up the phone and talk to
people if you have to
whatever whatever it takes you're going
to get through it and we'll help you
that's that's what we do
operation homefront is encouraging
anybody dealing with emergency
mental health struggles to contact the
national suicide prevention lifeline
that's at 1-800-273-talk they want every
service member
veteran and military family in our
community to know that you're not alone
back to yorko